These are the networking tips that I used to get my job at MALK.
Even though I didn't have as much experience in marketing as maybe somebody else,...
...I did use my network in order for me to get my foot in the door...
...and land me the job.
I was fortunate enough to have a friend who owns a lot of coffee shops...
...who happens to use MALK, the almond milk,...
...and he made the introduction between me and the CEO.
Whenever you're networking, you must always remember that you are planting seeds.
That one coffee or hello that you had one year...
...might lead you to the promotion that you want five years later at another company.
So, when I'm networking, I'm always looking for a face-to-face opportunity...
...just putting myself in front of that person,...
...shaking their hand and then offering to take him out to coffee.
Do the research on the brand and then get to know the person first.
It's just respecting their time...
...and getting them relaxed and comfortable with wanting to help you.
You want someone to champion for you.
Close it out with saying "If you want to keep in touch, here's my business card."
So, that's how I got my job, and I hope it helps you get yours.